antonio royal martinez is normally
pretty even-tempered but mentioned solar
energy and his hackles rise around ten
years ago he plowed a million euros into
a solar park his entire savings along
with a six hundred thousand euro loan
like many others he thought it was a
safe option a sector with guaranteed
government backing the Savings Bank said
to me royal if you're looking to invest
put your money into renewable energies
the sector looks like it's doing well at
the time the Spanish government was
eager to boost the solar energy sector
it called on the general public to get
on board and guaranteed a fixed price
for solar power fed into the grid 60,000
people heeded the call in the first year
royo earned 120 thousand euros but as
the recession took hold the government
cut its solar power subsidies good thing
I have 85 thousand euros costs a year
and I'm only making 70 thousand euros a
Pinto his faith has been shattered in
renewable energies and in the government
subsidies he feels the state has let him
down lawyer Juan Castro he'll
represented royal and other solar energy
producers who brought lawsuits over the
payment cuts the cases were lost in the
Supreme Court
no on see them we Spanish coats weren't
interested in our claims because they
felt they had to protect the state Rio
and the other investors agree and
they're not mincing their words yo I
don't trust the Spanish judiciary or the
government it was illegal to make the
cuts after the fact I think it's a
disgrace what makes things worse is that
other investors have been treated
differently 150 kilometres south of
Madrid there is a huge solar energy
power plant it's owned by a British in
investment fund which also objected to
the cuts in renewable subsidies
investors there didn't take their case
to the Spanish Court but to a private
arbitration tribunal an option that's
only open to foreign investors the
British investment fund was awarded more
than 120 million euros in compensation
Spain is facing dozens of other similar
claims that's unprecedented in the EU
German companies like RWE or Eon are
among them they declined to comment on
the case
the Spanish government also turned down
our request for an interview in a press
release the energy ministry expressed
its optimism that Spain wouldn't lose
any further claims and the small
investors they're frustrated cause I'm
annoyed the foreigners have won their
claims but we didn't at the same time it
gives me hope if they win then we might
have a second chance and the other solar
energy operators are hoping that their
lawyer will in the end ensure that they
get the subsidies promised to them but
he's not expecting Spanish courts to
come up with the goods he thinks the EU
will have to intervene of the cases
we've applied for the verdicts to be
presented before the European Court of
Justice for clarification but we can't
appeal directly a Spanish Court has to
do that they've refused up to no royo
we'll be getting some money from the
spanish state this year but it still has
a habit of bad payment practices
that's let the Royal disillusioned I
won't invest again once I've paid for
the solar plant I'll live off it but I'm
never going to put so much money into
something again
antonio royal martinez isn't the only
one who feels like this thousands of
other spaniards no longer believe their
government's promises in the end it's
the planet that could pay the price